En plein cœur des montagnes
de Nouvelle-Guinée Papouasie,
la tribu des Hulis vit encore
selon des coutumes ancestrales.
Ces images sont rares.
D'autant que ce mode de vie tend à
disparaître chaque jour un peu plus.
Aujourd'hui, c'est jour de fête.
Après 2 ans d'initiation
par les anciens du village,
les jeunes hommes se voient couper
les cheveux très courts,
lors d'une cérémonie au rituel codifié.
Sans leur coiffe, les jeunes adultes
ont désormais le droit de se marier.
Pour fêter ce nouveau statut,
les Hulis entament une danse millénaire.
Pour le chef du village,
cette tradition est en danger.
- Les jeunes portent des rastas,
se coupent les cheveux n'importe comment.
Le monde change et je ne peux pas
prédire l'avenir.
Nous faisons de notre mieux
pour préserver notre culture,
mais notre identité disparaît.
Je ne sais pas où ça va aller.
La crainte de ce chef Huli,
l'exploitation intensive de la forêt du pays
par des compagnies internationales.
Depuis plusieurs années,
chaque jour, des milliers
de tonnes de bois exotiques,
sont arrachés à la forêt
pour être vendus ensuite à l'étranger,
sans que les habitants
des zones exploitées en bénéficient.
- Ils ont exploité toutes nos terres.
Mais il n'y a pas eu
de développement ici !
Pas d'hôpitaux, pas de routes.
Ces compagnies ont pris nos arbres,
mais ils ne nous ont rien apporté.
Ils ont tout détruit !
Une forêt détruite,
une forêt qui se réduit,
et avec elle, toutes les traditions
ancestrales papoues.
Symbole de cette destruction, ce navire
chargé de milliers de troncs d'arbre,
en partance pour l'Europe.
La Nouvelle-Guinée Papouasie
est entrée dans une nouvelle ère,
pour le meilleur et pour le pire.
Avant d'attirer les investisseurs
du monde entier,
la Nouvelle-Guinée, au nord de l'Australie,
fut longtemps un bout du monde très isolé.
La partie orientale de l'île devint
membre du Commonwealth en 1918.
Indépendante depuis 1975,
c'est une monarchie parlementaire
dont le chef de l'État,
est encore symboliquement Elizabeth II,
reine d'Angleterre.
Ici en visite en 1977.
Un peu moins grande que la France,
c'est une terre de volcans,
une terre principalement montagneuse,
recouverte de forêts vierges
à perte de vue.
Des poumons verts qui abritent une faune
et une flore d'une rare diversité.
Un paradis pour les randonneurs
venus du monde entier.
L'écrasante majorité des 8 millions
d'habitants du pays est Papou,
et vit encore dans les terres,
principalement de l'agriculture.
Fuyant la misère des campagnes,
les jeunes ruraux sont de plus en plus
nombreux à venir s'échouer en ville,
sans emplois, désoeuvrés,
ils viennent gonfler les rangs
des gangs locaux.
Résultat : l'année dernière,
Port Moresby a été classé,
deuxième des capitales les plus violentes
au monde, derrière Caracas, au Venezuela.
Ici, la police mène une guerre impitoyable
contre les Raskols,
les gangs violents des bidonvilles.
- On ne rentre plus dans ce quartier.
Jack est un de ces chefs Raskols.
- On lui a tiré dessus neuf fois et il n'est
jamais mort. On l'appelle "bulletproof",
à l'épreuve des balles.
Lui et ses hommes font régner la terreur
avec des armes qu'ils fabriquent eux-mêmes.
- Je peux en faire à deux canons
et cinq ou six coups.
Le pays ne compte plus
les attaques violentes.
Les vols de voitures avec armes
ou encore les braquages.
- Ils tirent sur les gens.
Parfois ils ont des couteaux
et ils les poignardent.
Si la Nouvelle-Guinée-Papouasie
est aussi violente,
c'est notamment parce que la richesse
y est très mal répartie.
Alors que son sous-sol regorge d'or,
de cuivre, de zinc, de pétrole et de gaz.
Grâce à ses richesses,
le pays connaît depuis dix ans,
un boom immobilier inégalé,
et l'émergence d'une riche bourgeoisie.
Parmi elles, certains cassent
les codes et les clichés, comme Jessie,
gérante d'une boite de nuit à succès.
- On ne vit pas tous dans des huttes,
on ne porte pas tous
des vêtements traditionnels !
Extrême richesse, extrême pauvreté,
violence endémique et traditions
ancestrales qui disparaissent,
Enquête exclusive au paradis perdu
de Nouvelle-Guinée-Papouasie.
À quelques centaines de mètres
des rives paradisiaques,
de Port Moresby, la capitale.
- Braquage dans une épicerie indienne.
- Allez-y !
- Qu'est-ce qui se passe ?
- Un braquage dans la zone !
Il faut faire vite.
Selon les dernières informations,
Deux braqueurs sont partis
se cacher dans le secteur.
Nous entrons dans le bidonville
où ils se seraient repliés.
Les policiers connaissent bien le terrain.
- Ils sont où ?
- Ils sont là-haut, au même endroit.
- Au même endroit ?
- Oui au même endroit
où on est venu la dernière fois.
- Ok, on se sépare maintenant.
Les policiers tentent de prendre
à revers les voleurs.
- Tu vérifies à l'intérieur.
Le lieutenant David fouille
les abris de tôle une à une.
- Il n'y a personne ici.
Après quelques minutes,
son coéquipier finit par trouver un homme.
Rien n'indique qu'il est impliqué
dans le braquage,
pourtant, les policiers
l'arrêtent sans ménagement.
- Ne bouge pas !
- Laissez-moi partir.
Ici, pas de présomption d'innocence,
ni de respect basique du suspect.
Il est maintenu au sol à coups de rangers.
- Il était où ?
- Juste là, à l'intérieur.
En guise de menottes, les policiers
utilisent une laisse pour chien.
- On l'emmène. On va l'interroger
pour qu'il nous donne les autres.
Il connaît les autres. C'est un gang.
Il sait où ils habitent
et où ils emmènent l'argent.
Même devant notre caméra,
les policiers n'hésitent pas à frapper,
sans raison le suspect.
- Parfois, enfin, souvent,
La police de Papouasie tire sur les gens.
S'il avait continué à courir,
je lui aurais tiré dans la jambe.
- À terre ! Baisse-toi.
Baisse-toi tout de suite !
On a réussi à en attraper un.
C'est une bonne chose. On est contents.
- Face contre terre !
Tu ne t'assieds pas ! Reste comme ça.
Les policiers veulent identifier
formellement l'homme arrêté.
À leur arrivée à l'épicerie
qui s'est fait braquer,
le gérant est sur ses gardes.
Les attaques de commerces par
des policiers corrompus sont nombreux ici.
- Viens me voir. On doit parler.
- On n'a pas envie d'ouvrir.
- On ne va pas vous voler. L'un de vous
doit venir identifier l'homme qu'on a arrêté.
Un employé finit par sortir.
Il va être confronté au suspect.
- Je me tenais là.
Ils ont sorti leurs armes.
Très proche de la scène,
son témoignage va s'avérer capital.
Mais surprise.
- Non, ce n'est pas lui.
- Ce n'est pas lui ?
- Non.
L'employé est formel. Le suspect
interpellé et violenté est innocent.
Malaise, silence gêné,
les policiers veulent vérifier
que l'homme qu'ils ont arrêté,
est vraiment hors de cause.
Ils demandent à visionner
les images de vidéosurveillance.
- Tu vas voir, il y en a un
qui va sortir un couteau,
et l'autre une arme à feu.
- Celui-là avec des rastas.
- Oui, celui-là avec le T-shirt blanc.
- Le deuxième n'a pas de rastas.
- Et il a un T-shirt noir.
La vidéo confirme le témoignage
de l'employée.
Les policiers ont bien commis une bavure.
Le suspect est libéré.
- On lui enlève ça.
Pas question de compensations,
ni même d'excuses.
- Vas-y, lève-toi !
- Assieds-toi sur la banquette.
Le suspect n'obtiendra qu'un peu d'eau
pour rincer sa bouche ensanglantée.
Quant aux vrais braqueurs,
ils courent toujours.
Ces voleurs armés
qui font régner la terreur,
nous avons pu exceptionnellement
en rencontrer,
dans ce bidonville sur pilotis.
À l'origine, Hanuabada
est un ancien village de pêcheurs.
Avec l'exode rural massif
de ces dernières années,
il a grossi jusqu'à atteindre
15 000 habitants.
Abandonné de tous,
le quartier s'enfonce chaque jour,
un peu plus dans la misère et la violence.
Une zone de non-droit, où la police
ne rentre plus depuis deux ans déjà.
C'est la base arrière de Jack,
l'un des plus importants chefs mafieux.
Après plusieurs semaines
de contacts répétés,
il a finalement accepté
de nous parler sans détour.
- Si on monte un coup, il faut d'abord
voler une voiture pour le faire.
On dit à un jeune d'en trouver une.
Il fait un car-jacking.
On l'amène ici, dans un endroit sûr.
On change les plaques,
on prépare le matériel
comme les armes et tout ça.
On discute du plan,
où et comment l'exécuter.
Le coup part d'ici,
on le fait et on revient ici.
Avec son look de bon père de famille,
il peut sembler inoffensif,
mais il ne faut pas s'y fier.
Son pédigrée est étoffé.
Premier braquage d'un automobiliste
à seize ans,
puis les attaques vont s'enchaîner.
Dans le campement,
pourrissent les voitures volées,
qui ont servi au braquage
de Jack et ses hommes.
Ce jour-là, le chef du gang
a une affaire à régler.
Une de ces spécialités, moins risquées
que les attaques à main armée,
le vol de voitures de luxe.
- On va essayer de voler
un Toyota Land Cruiser, cinq portes.
Le propriétaire, le gare à la marina.
Il vit sur un yacht.
Il dort dedans.
Le matin, il part au travail.
Jack a déjà fait refaire un double de clé.
Ne lui manque plus que de faux papiers.
Au fil des ans, le chef de gang,
a su développer un réseau
de complices très efficace.
- Vous allez voir un de vos hommes ?
- Oui. Il va nous donner
les photos de notre cible.
- Teddy, je veux les photos.
On la vole et on la met
dans un garage sûr.
Quand l'acheteur est OK,
on utilise notre réseau,
dans les compagnies d'assurance
pour refaire les papiers.
Il change les papiers,
ça a un coût,
mais après le véhicule lui appartient.
- Combien vous pouvez la vendre ?
- Si c'est une vente rapide,
14 000€ parce qu'elle est d'occasion.
C'est assez sûr et le risque
de se faire tirer dessus est de zéro.
Pour rester discret
et éviter les contrôles,
Jack vit toujours dans le quartier pauvre
de Kigari, au nord est de la ville.
- Là, c'est ma maison.
Voici ma famille.
Ma mère, enfin celle qui
s'est occupée de moi.
Ce n'est pas ma mère biologique,
mais elle s'est occupée de moi.
Ma sœur. Une autre sœur.
Une tante, la sœur de mon père.
- Vous êtes fiers de votre fils ?
- Oui, je suis fière de lui.
- Pourquoi ?
- Parce que je me fais vieille
et lui aussi, mais il prend soin de moi.
Chef d'un gang criminel,
Jack est aussi soutien de famille.
Et aime donner l'image d'un défenseur
de la veuve et l'orphelin.
- Quand vous étiez enfant,
quel était votre rêve ?
- Je voulais devenir avocat.
À cause de mon histoire familiale.
Mon père était un criminel.
Je me suis donc concentré
sur mes études pour devenir avocat.
Je voulais rendre justice
aux gens de mon quartier.
À ceux qui subissent autant d'injustice.
Ce que je fais aujourd'hui,
ce n'est pas pour moi,
mais pour l'avenir de mes enfants.
À défaut d'haranguer les prétoires,
Jack s'est spécialisé dans le crime.
Pour monter ses opérations,
le chef de gang a besoin d'armes,
et pour ça, il a un fournisseur maison.
- J'utilise un morceau de tube en acier.
Je vais l'assembler et tu vas voir.
Cet armurier que nous appellerons John,
exerce ses talents depuis 28 ans.
C'est la première fois que le gang
de Jack accepte qu'il soit filmé.
Il ne travaille que pour les Raskols.
- Quand les gars cherchent une arme,
ils viennent et je leur fournis.
Ils font des hold-up, des cambriolages,
des vols de voitures.
John fabrique en moyenne
une arme par mois.
Si ses outils et sa technique
sont pour le moins rudimentaires,
une certitude, le produit fini
est très efficace.
- Ces armes tuent parfois des policiers ?
- Oui !
Là, je mets la cartouche.
Je le remets comme ça, je le revisse.
J'arme et voilà, c'est prêt.
- Vous mettez quoi comme munition ?
- Des cartouches de chasse.
- Et comment vous les trouvez ?
- C'est la police municipale.
Je leur demande, je leur donne
de l'argent et ils m'en donnent.
- C'est dangereux parfois ?
Ça peut exploser ?
- Non, ça marche normalement.
Combien de temps faut-il
pour en fabriquer une ?
- Environ 1 h, c'est tout.
Je peux en faire à deux canons
et cinq ou six coups.
Je peux le faire.
Pour moi, c'est très simple.
Je n'en fabrique pas beaucoup,
c'est dangereux.
Les acheteurs viennent les prendre
et c'est tout.
Je ne fabrique qu'à la demande.
Une activité très risquée pour John.
Si la police l'arrête,
il encourt dix ans de prison.
- Combien coûte une arme comme celle-là ?
- Celle-là vaut 260€.
Un prix élevé, car se procurer des
armes ici est particulièrement difficile.
À l'autre bout du pays, Goroka,
à 420 kilomètres
au nord-est de Port Moresby.
Ici, chaque mois de septembre,
depuis les années 50,
se tient un festival où se réunissent
des représentants de 70 tribus.
Le pays en compte 800
pour autant de langues,
soit 10% de toutes les langues
parlées sur la planète.
Une richesse culturelle unique au monde.
Pendant deux jours, hommes, femmes
et enfants, venus parfois de très loin,
exposent au public leurs chants
et danses traditionnelles,
maquillés de peintures
de guerre ancestrales.
- On décore les masques
avec de grandes dents, de la peinture,
des yeux exorbités
et un gros nez pour faire peur.
Comme si nos ancêtres revenaient
sous forme d'esprits.
En portant ce masque,
je montre ma culture.
Et je la transmets aux enfants.
Les enfants de mon village doivent porter
ce masque, sinon notre culture va mourir.
Il faut continuer de le porter.
Rendez-vous culturel, cet événement
pacifique a aussi pour but,
de conjurer la violence de ces sociétés,
où les guerres ethniques
sont encore bien réelles.
Des conflits où les protagonistes
ont désormais troqué les arcs et les flèches,
pour les armes à feu.
Le dernier en date, le 10 juillet 2019,
a fait 32 morts, dont 9 enfants,
entre deux tribus du nord du pays.
Cette violence tribale endémique,
s'expliquerait aussi par la disparition
rapide des traditions locales.
- Nous, les anciens,
on vient ici et on observe,
qu'il y a beaucoup de jeunes
qui ne suivent plus les traditions.
Ils ne trouvent plus de plaisir
dans la vie qu'on leur propose.
Avec son histoire et ses coutumes.
Si les enfants ne font rien,
alors, ils vont se mettre à voler,
à traîner dehors.
Et ce ne sont pas de bonnes habitudes.
Donc on les incite à garder nos traditions,
à venir ici, à danser
et à gagner un peu d'argent.
Depuis quelques années,
le festival est devenu un moyen
de subsistance pour ces tribus.
Conservatoires des traditions,
c'est aussi désormais un rendez-vous
artificiel pour touristes fortunés,
en mal d'exotisme.
Entre l'avion depuis la capitale,
deux nuits d'hôtel minimum
et l'accès aux festivals,
il faut compter au moins
1000 euros par personne.
La seule entrée sur le site coûte 150€,
inabordable pour l'immense majorité
des habitants du pays,
qui doivent rester
à l'extérieur de l'enceinte.
Là, pour rentrer en même temps
que les groupes, c'est trop cher.
Ce n'est pas bien qu'on reste dehors
alors que les touristes sont à l'intérieur.
Clou de ce spectacle folklorique,
les Mudman ou homme boue.
- Non, attendez, pas là !
- Nous sommes les hommes boue !
- On apprécie beaucoup.
Tous ces gens sont tellement beaux.
- J'aime ce genre d'événement.
J'adore l'énergie, les couleurs.
J'aime surtout les gens qui font des choses
pas seulement pour les touristes.
Un regard naïf sur ce rassemblement
où tout s'achète.
Photos, armes traditionnelles,
poteries et sculptures.
dont le best-seller,
ces figurines de Mudman en argile.
- 13€ pour deux.
- Lequel tu veux ?
Tout a un prix.
Même nos questions sont payantes.
- Si vous voulez nous poser
d'autres questions et nous filmer,
il va falloir payer.
- Oui, donnez au moins 2 ou 3€, parce que
vous posez beaucoup de questions.
À 13 h, les locaux peuvent enfin
assister au festival à tarif réduit.
3€ le billet.
Et pour les pickpockets, la possibilité
de faire de bonnes affaires.
- Vous avez volé combien ?
- On a récolté environ 125€.
125€. Soit quasiment
un mois de salaire ici.
De l'argent facile dans
ce coin reculé où sans emploi,
de nombreux Papous ne font que survivre.
Après le festival Sing-sing,
nous avons poussé notre voyage
au cœur même des montagnes du pays.
Ici, la forêt vierge couvre près
des trois quarts du territoire,
et recèle de trésors naturels
sans équivalent.
20 000 variétés de plantes.
3000 familles d'insectes.
Plus de 800 espèces d'oiseaux,
dont le fameux oiseau de paradis,
ainsi que de très nombreuses
chauves-souris.
C'est aux marges de ces paysages
époustouflants que vivent les Mudmen,
les célèbres hommes boue.
Nous sommes au village d'Azzaro.
Jim est le chef de cette communauté
de quelques centaines de personnes.
Au quotidien, pas de masque
ni de boue sur le corps.
La tradition aujourd'hui, pour eux,
c'est avant tout du folklore,
qu'ils vendent aux touristes.
- On peut le vendre 50€
si les touristes veulent l'acheter.
- Je mets des dents de cochon.
Ça me prend un jour pour finir le masque.
- Quand les touristes viennent,
on danse pour eux et on gagne de l'argent.
S'ils ne viennent pas, on ne fait pas
de danse et on ne gagne rien.
Ici, tout le monde travaille
pour les touristes.
Sans pension de retraite, les seniors,
eux aussi, tentent de gagner quelques euros.
Hormis ces maigres revenus, les Mudmen
ne survivent que grâce à la Terre.
- Au village, on plante toujours des patates
douces car un sac vaut entre 13 et 18€.
Vous voyez, là, il y a une patate douce.
Mais elle n'est pas encore prête.
Une culture rentable dont le surplus
sera vendu au marché de Goroka.
Pas de quoi permettre aux parents
d'envoyer leurs enfants à l'école,
ou de s'acheter des biens
de consommation courante.
Comme la majorité des villages papous,
Azzaro n'est pas relié à l'électricité
ni à l'eau potable.
Pour joindre les deux bouts,
le village a développé une autre activité,
une activité illégale.
Un peu à l'écart, Jim nous emmène
vers cette petite case.
Ici, on fabrique de l'alcool.
Ces bananes sont mûres
et ces citrons aussi.
En charge de la fabrication,
Eric nous explique sa méthode.
- En bas, ce n'est pas assez chaud,
donc je mets le seau sur le toit.
Il fait beaucoup plus chaud en hauteur
et l'eau s'évapore.
Un système D ultra-artisanal.
- Tu vois, c'est ce jus là
que je vais chauffer ensuite.
Artisanal mais très efficace.
Avec son alambic fait maison,
Eric réussit à obtenir un alcool
extrêmement fort,
entre 60 et 70 degrés.
- Parfois, les gens peuvent devenir
violents à cause de ça ?
- Oui, ils se battent. Certains même
mettent le feu à leur maison.
Cet alcool, ça rend fou.
Certains tuent leur femme
ou leurs enfants.
- C'est trop fort ?
- C'est du bon alcool,
mais c'est trop fort.
À 4€ le litre d'alcool de bananes,
le petit trafiquant n'est pas très riche.
Alors pour compléter ses revenus,
il a aussi développé un business
encore plus risqué,
la culture du c****.
- C'est un très bon business.
Ça vaut de l'or pour nous.
La police ne doit pas le voir.
C'est trop dangereux.
Si on est pris avec ça, on va
en prison pendant 5 ou 10 ans.
Des risques importants
pour survivre au quotidien.
En Papouasie-Nouvelle-Guinée,
peu échappent à la misère.
Seule, une infime minorité
profite des richesses du pays.
Retour à Port Moresby,
nous sommes au Gold Club,
la plus grosse boite de nuit
de la capitale.
Ici, la jeunesse dorée et les expatriés
viennent faire la fête,
sur des standards
de house musique occidentale.
Sur la piste de danse, des femmes.
Aux platines, encore des femmes.
Et pour gérer le tout,
Jackie, la manager,
très fière de son établissement.
- C'est l'endroit où il faut être.
On peut croiser tout le monde.
Vous pouvez rencontrer le Premier ministre
comme votre voisin de palier.
Tout le monde est là pour s'amuser,
se relaxer et passer du bon temps.
Tout le monde peut s'amuser.
Tout le monde ? Enfin, pas vraiment.
À 7€ l'entrée et 4€ le demi de bière,
le Gold Club est réservé
à l'élite du pays.
Gardé par de nombreux agents de sécurité,
l'établissement est un îlot de tranquillité,
loin de la violence qui gangrène la capitale.
- On est heureux de pouvoir montrer
une autre image de la Papouasie aux étrangers.
On ne vit pas tous
dans des villages avec des huttes.
On ne porte pas tous des vêtements
traditionnels avec le visage.
À l'étage du dessous, Jackie nous montre
la mine d'or du club,
les machines à sous.
- Jackie, comment ça va ?
- Très bien, merci.
- Ça fait plaisir de te voir !
- Ce sont mes clients réguliers.
Ils aiment venir ici,
passer un bon moment.
- C'est comme Las Vegas !
Mais ici, on connaît les gens.
Jackie soigne ses habitués.
Et pour cause.
Grâce à une cinquantaine de machines,
chaque soir, le Gold Club,
engrange des milliers d'euros.
- Salut les gars !
Bonne chance avec les machines.
Jackie n'est pas propriétaire du club.
Elle travaille pour Yannis Nikolaou.
Cet immigré Grec est arrivée
dans le pays sans diplôme,
et sans argent à l'âge de 18 ans.
35 ans plus tard, il est aujourd'hui
à la tête d'un empire de la nuit florissant.
Le lendemain matin,
Yannis accepte notre interview,
et nous donne rendez vous à la marina
où il a ses habitudes.
Ce petit port abrite les plus beaux
voiliers et yacht du pays.
À lui seul, Yannis en possède 5.
- Ça c'est un de mes bateaux.
- Et il coûte combien ce bateau ?
- Environ 300 000€.
Un autre de ses bateaux,
celui qui sert à emmener en balade
ses clients les plus fortunés.
- Quel est le prix approximatif
de ce bateau ?
Pour ce bateau... Ça doit être...
1,2 million.
Yannis est devenu multimillionnaire
grâce à son travail,
mais aussi parce qu'il fut
un des premiers Occidentaux,
à venir faire du business à Port Moresby.
À l'époque, tout était à faire.
- C'est nous qui avons développé ici
les machines à sous.
Notre licence nationale d'exploitation
porte le numéro 001.
Donc on est les premiers
à avoir eu les machines.
Et maintenant, on est à la tête
de la plus grosse salle,
de machines à sous du pays.
Si on suit son rêve ou son but,
ça se réalise.
Le succès à Port Moresby ne serait
donc qu'une question de volonté.
Mais lorsque nous évoquons
la corruption rampante ici,
Yannis est tout de suite
beaucoup moins à l'aise.
- On a lu dans les journaux
qu'il y a de la corruption.
Oui, ce n'est pas vraiment à moi
de faire des commentaires sur la corruption.
Je pense que ça pourrait
nous attirer des problèmes.
Chaque année, la Nouvelle-Guinée-Papouasie
est classée dans le top 10,
des pays les plus corrompus
de la planète.
Symbole de ce fléau, ce bâtiment
d'architecte autrichien renommé,
qui a coûté plus de 30 millionsd'euros.
Une folie des grandeurs inaugurée en 2018,
pour accueillir le sommet de l'APEC,
l'organisme de coopération économique
pour l'Asie Pacifique.
Pour y conduire les 21 chefs d'État
de l'organisation,
le gouvernement
du Premier ministre Peter O'Neill,
a acheté sur fonds publics
des dizaines de Maserati.
Coût pour le contribuable
près de 8 millionsd'euros.
Aujourd'hui, le bâtiment est vide.
Quant aux voitures de luxe, plus personne
ne les a vues depuis cet événement.
Après enquête,
nous finissons par apprendre,
qu'elles dormiraient
dans ces hangars non loin.
À notre arrivée, le garde nous confirme
leur présence derrière ces grilles.
- Elles sont où les Maserati ?
- À l'intérieur du bâtiment.
- Si on vous donne 25 ou 50€
pour les voir...
- On va voir.
Ironie de l'histoire, c'est en le corrompant,
lui et son collègue,
que nous allons pouvoir filmer
discrètement ces voitures.
80€ et on ne reste que 5 minutes.
- Ok. Passez par la porte principale.
À l'intérieur, 40 Maserati flambant
neuves à 200 000€ l'unité.
40 bolides qui prennent
la poussière depuis plus d'un an.
L'achat de ces voitures a fait scandale
dans ce pays rongé par la misère.
Mais rien n'a changé.
Non seulement le ministre responsable
de cet achat n'a pas été inquiété,
mais il est même resté en place.
S'il avait été condamné,
ce ministre serait sans doute,
passé par la plus grande prison du pays,
le centre pénitentiaire de Bomana,
à quelques kilomètres de la capitale.
- Ceux qui portent un uniforme
doivent venir au poste de sécurité.
Quand vous entendrez votre nom,
rendez vous au poste de sécurité.
Sous ces baraques de tôle rouillée,
violeurs, meurtriers
ou Raskols braqueurs,
cohabitent sans distinction de crime.
Ici, l'administration sépare uniquement,
les condamnés de ceux
qui attendent leur procès,
comme cet homme présent derrière
ces grilles depuis un an déjà.
- Pour meurtre ?
- Oui.
Dans cette prison, on manque de tout.
Manque de moyens, manque de personnel.
Seuls quatre surveillants non armés
pour 600 détenus.
- On travaille comme ça, sans arme.
On utilise la parole
et notre cerveau pour les calmer.
Et comment faites-vous
pour les contenir sans arme ?
- Il y a une alarme là.
Quand on ne peut plus contenir
un groupe, on appelle du renfort.
Avec l'alarme, le renfort arrive
et nous soutient dans notre travail.
Mais les renforts, ces 4 gardes
n'y font que rarement appel.
Anciennement prison la plus
dangereuse du pays,
Bomana a vu sa situation
s'améliorer depuis 5 ans.
Pour s'acheter la paix, la nouvelle
direction a demandé aux prisonniers,
de gérer leur sécurité.
En échange, ils ont obtenu plus
de liberté à l'intérieur du site.
Un donnant-donnant qui semble marcher.
- C'est un de nos chefs, ici.
Chaque baraquement
a son chef de la sécurité.
Dans celui-ci, le boss,
c'est Joe, 45 ans.
- J'ai grandi en prison.
Depuis l'âge de 11, 12 ans,
J'ai fait des séjours ici.
Différents séjours pour différents crimes,
vols à main armée, braquages,
et même meurtres
pour le dernier en date.
Condamné à 25 ans de prison,
Joe va encore rester ici jusqu'en 2025.
Son quotidien : cette baraque dortoir
au confort très rudimentaire.
- Ici, c'est mon espace.
C'est mon coin. C'est là que je dors.
Je n'ai pas de couverture pour dormir.
Quand le climat est vraiment
très chaud, la planche est brûlante.
Quand le climat change, le vent entre,
et ça, ça me rafraîchit.
Mais quand il fait trop chaud,
je dors par terre sur le ciment.
Vous êtes combien dans ce bâtiment ?
Ce bâtiment est prévu pour 42 personnes.
Mais parfois, c'est surpeuplé.
Ça peut monter à 53, 56.
Ici, les prisonniers
n'ont pas de matelas pour dormir.
Pas de télévision, pas de téléphone.
Sauf pour certains privilégiés comme Joe.
- Vous avez un téléphone portable ?
- Oui, j'en ai un.
- On peut le voir ?
- Oui. Regardez.
- Donc c'est possible ?
- C'est possible.
Avec un peu d'argent,
un peu de corruption,
les prisonniers arrivent à améliorer
leurs conditions de détention.
Mais gare à ceux qui
se font prendre à ce petit jeu.
Derrière ce rideau de fer, le mitard.
Dans ce tout petit espace, les détenus
passent entre quelques semaines,
et quelques mois
sans aucune possibilité de sortir.
- Regardez comme c'est ici.
Il n'y a même pas d'eau courante.
Ces hommes sont tous là
pour la même raison.
Ils ont enfreint
une des règles de la prison.
- L'incident est arrivé
à cause de l'alcool.
- À l'intérieur de la prison,
il y a de l'alcool ?
- Oui.
- Comment vous arrivez à trouver
de l'alcool, des téléphones,
enfin toutes ces choses ?
- C'est une bonne question.
C'est un peu confidentiel.
Vous voyez ce que je veux dire.
Le détenu est prudent. Un gardien
se tient juste dans notre dos.
- C'est facile de payer les gardiens ?
- Oui.
- Ils prennent l'argent et vous le donne ?
C'est comme ça que ça marche ?
Oui.
Après des années d'enfermement
et d'isolement,
l'administration pénitentiaire,
autorise parfois les détenus
à sortir en semi-liberté.
Nous sommes au marché central
de Port Moresby.
Ce matin, des prisonniers
sous haute surveillance,
vont en nettoyer les abords.
- Écartez vous, faites de la place !
Tous les prisonniers ne participent
pas à ces travaux d'intérêt généraux.
Condition requise : être méritants,
mais aussi être en fin de peine.
- Ils n'ont que quelques mois
avant leur sortie.
Ils ont fait Le plus dur.
Avant de penser à s'échapper,
ils vont se dire :
"Il me reste que quelques mois,
donc je n'ai pas besoin de m'échapper."
On ne choisit pas les prisonniers
condamnés à vie.
Car s'ils venaient ici,
ils tenteraient de s'échapper.
Ces prisonniers dans la rue,
un événement insolite,
qui attire de nombreux curieux.
Parmi eux, certains ont
de bonnes raisons d'être là.
- C'est la seule chance pour
les familles de voir les prisonniers.
On peut les voir et leur parler.
L'occasion de retrouvailles touchantes
et parfois étonnantes.
Ce détenu n'a pas vu ses filles
depuis neuf ans.
Au vu de son passé criminel,
on s'étonne même qu'il les voit encore.
- Ce sont mes 2 filles.
Elles étaient petites
quand je les ai laissées.
Ça fait combien de temps
que vous ne les avez pas vu ?
- Environ neuf ans.
Depuis que je suis en prison.
Elles étaient très jeunes.
- Et pourquoi vous êtes en prison ?
J'ai tué ma femme, leur mère.
- Pourquoi avez-vous tué votre femme ?
- C'était une erreur.
Pour la famille,
des moments toujours éprouvants.
C'est très dur de s'occuper des enfants.
On n'a pas le temps d'aller le voir.
Notre seule chance,
c'est qu'ils viennent ici.
Des histoires comme celle
de ce père meurtrier,
la Papouasie ne les compte plus.
Ici, les femmes paient
un tribut particulièrement élevé,
à la violence des hommes.
80% d'entre eux admettent frapper
régulièrement leurs épouses,
et une femme sur deux serait
victime de v*** durant sa vie.
- Mon mari était jaloux, il a pris
une pierre et m'a frappé la jambe.
Après, il est sorti.
Il est devenu fou.
Il a pris cette barre en fer,
il est venu et il a essayé de me taper.
J'ai crié et j'ai été me mettre
à l'abri derrière ma mère.
Lydia, 20 ans, se rend cet après-midi
à l'Armée du Salut,
un des rares centres d'accueil
pour femmes violentées du pays.
Elle vient y chercher une aide médicale,
mais aussi et surtout un refuge.
- Ça vous fait mal ?
- Oui, j'ai mal.
- Il l'a frappé dans le dos aussi
avec la barre en fer.
- Tu as l'impression que ton os est cassé ?
- Je ne sais pas.
- Demain, on va s'occuper de toi à la clinique.
Aujourd'hui, c'est mercredi.
Ils doivent fermer là.
Tu penses que tu vas pouvoir dormir
une nuit ici ? Ça va aller ?
- Oui, ça va aller.
- Quand vous retournez chez vous,
nous ne dites rien à personne.
Vous ne dites surtout pas où elle est.
- Non, on ne dira rien.
- Vous avez des amies qui ont déjà
été battues par leur mari ?
- Ça arrive souvent ?
- Oui, c'est fréquent.
Cette nuit, Lydia et sa petite fille
seront enfin en sécurité.
Le lendemain, après avoir reçu des soins,
la jeune femme a le courage d'aller porter
plainte au commissariat de son quartier.
Ici, les cas comme ceux
de Lydia sont très fréquents.
Cette femme avec son enfant a, elle aussi,
été battue le matin même.
Elle porte sur son visage les stigmates
de la violence de son mari.
- La première fois qu'il l'a frappé,
c'était au niveau des hanches.
Elle était enceinte à ce moment-là.
Aujourd'hui, il l'a frappée au visage,
avec une pierre, il lui a tapé la tête.
Ses frères sont arrivés,
ils ont réussi à contenir son mari.
Elle a pu s'enfuir.
De son côté, Lydia est enfin reçue
dans un bureau,
spécialement dédié
aux violences domestiques.
- Vous voulez porter plainte ou pas ?
- Oui, c'est pour ça qu'ils nous
ont envoyés ici,
pour que je puisse tout vous raconter.
- Je vais d'abord prendre votre déposition.
Lydia verra-t-elle sa plainte aboutir ?
Peu probable.
L'année dernière, l'instruction de plus des 3/4
des dossiers de violence conjugale,
n'a rien donné.
Retour en centre-ville.
Nous retrouvons Jack,
le Chef Raskol.
Il veut nous faire la démonstration que tout
peut s'acheter ici, surtout les policiers.
- Par là !
Un de nos amis vient de se faire arrêter
à un barrage routier car il n'a pas son permis.
Vous allez voir la corruption.
On va leur donner de l'argent
et ils vont le relâcher.
- La police lui a demandé de l'argent ?
- C'est typique !
C'est comme ça en Papouasie-Nouvelle-Guinée.
D'en haut jusqu'en bas, ce sont tous
des e**** de corrompus.
Quelques minutes plus tard,
le chef du gang arrive sur les lieux.
- C'est ici. Gare-toi devant.
L'ami de Jack, c'est l'homme
au tee-shirt rouge et béquilles.
Avant notre arrivée,
il a déjà négocié avec un agent,
l'amende à la baisse.
Autour du chef des policiers de venir
maintenant finaliser la négociation.
- Combien mon collègue vous a demandé ?
- 50€.
- C'est ta dernière chance.
Normalement, vous devriez
payer l'amende la plus élevée.
Là, il vous demande 50€.
J'ai le sentiment que ce n'est rien.
- Oui, je sais, votre collègue
m'a dit que c'était la loi.
- Oui, normalement, il devrait te demander
80€ en plus.
Le policier les laisserait
partir contre 50€,
une somme qui représente tout de même
un tiers du SMIC local.
Jacques donne les billets à son ami.
Le deal va pouvoir se conclure.
- Alors ?
- Ils ont dit que c'était bon.
Ils demandaient 130€ et on a fait
baisser à 50€. On a négocié.
Cette corruption chez les policiers est
monnaie courante en Papouasie-Nouvelle-Guinée.
Elle s'apparente même à du racket.
Port Moresby est quadrillée de points
de contrôle où la moindre infraction,
fait l'objet d'une négociation pour remplir
les poches des fonctionnaires.
Des policiers au parcours
et à la proximité avec les voyous,
parfois très étonnants.
- Ce sont des officiers
de la police municipale.
Lui, c'est Akéliomo, un Nigérian.
Mais pour les gens du quartier
de Bamuru ou de Boroko,
c'est un e**** !
C'est comme mon frère, on a été en prison
ensemble, il y a quelques années.
Avant, il était très costaud,
comme cinq ou dix hommes.
Maintenant, il a pris du ventre.
À l'époque, il était vraiment costaud.
- Comme j'ai ce passé,
je sais qui sont les bons et les mauvais.
Du coup, je peux mieux
assister les officiers.
Quand il arrive quelque chose, on sait
où aller parce qu'on sait qui l'a fait,
ou qui ne l'a pas fait.
Si un policier a des doutes,
on sait comment appréhender le fautif.
- Ok les gars, je vais me balader.
Salut !
Ces policiers sont à la botte
du chef Raskols.
Jack ne s'attarde pas.
- Parfois, vous avez des informations
par la police ?
- Oui, j'ai des contacts.
Mais ils ne sont pas là.
Oui, ils me donnent des informations
ou ce que je veux savoir.
Parfois, ils nous aident même
en nous donnant des armes.
- Ils vous donnent des armes ?
- Oui, ces e**** sont en bas de l'échelle.
Mes gars sont plus gradés qu'eux.
Avec l'aide ou non de la police
pour monter ses coups,
le chef de gang réunit souvent
ses associés loin des regards.
- C'est un endroit sécurisé où on peut
venir discuter de différentes choses.
- C'est un endroit sûr ?
- Oui, ici, c'est sûr.
Ses partenaires de crime,
des amis de longue date,
aux corps marqués par des années
d'affrontements avec la police.
- On lui a tiré dessus 9 fois
à différentes occasions.
Il n'est jamais mort.
C'est pour ça qu'on l'appelle bulletproof,
à l'épreuve des balles.
- J'en ai pris une première fois là.
Une deuxième là, au M16.
Dans le bras.
Dans l'estomac.
On faisait un cambriolage avec des amis.
Un policier m'a tiré dessus.
Et moi, j'en ai tué trois.
- Ils ont tiré là.
La balle est toujours là.
- Et vous ne voulez pas l'enlever ?
- C'est risqué. Ils pourraient
couper un nerf ou quelque chose,
et je me retrouverais paralysé.
- Donc, vous la gardez ?
- Oui.
Il garde la balle et vous ?
- Moi, j'en ai reçu une dans les fesses.
Et elle est ressortie par ma b***.
Je pensais vraiment
que ma b*** serait perdue !
Mais par chance, quand j'ai regardé
en bas, tout allait bien.
Face à la police toujours plus répressive,
Jack monte aujourd'hui ses coups,
avec ses anciens rivaux.
Désormais, les Tontons flingueurs
partagent tout jusqu'au bétel.
Très prisé ici, cette plante
se mâche pour ses vertus euphorisantes.
Particularité :
elle teint les dents rouges.
- Maintenant, on s'unit. Toi, tu
te charges de voler les voitures.
Lui, il trouve une arme ou plusieurs.
On trouve un endroit discret,
on s'organise et...
Quand c'est le bon moment, on le fait.
Et tout ce qu'on a, 4000, 5000, 6 000€,
on se le partage.
Maintenant,
quand je vois les jeunes arriver,
"Tu fais ceci, tu fais ça
et tu ne l'ouvres pas !"
- Le code, ce que nous appelons
le code du silence,
si on réalise une opération avec succès,
et que suite à son enquête,
la police arrête l'un de nous.
Tu dois rester muet.
Tu n'as pas intérêt à donner
ni son nom, ni mon nom.
Non !
Si tu parles et que tu donnes
des informations,
quand il ira en prison,
ce b**** se fera défoncer.
À eux trois, ces chefs de gang ont passé
près de 20 ans derrière les barreaux.
Selon Jack, ils auraient
dû en faire 3 fois plus,
s'ils n'avaient pas eu l'argent
pour payer les juges.
Le nouveau gouvernement,
nommé l'année dernière,
a promis de faire de la lutte
contre la corruption, sa priorité.
Comme tous ses prédécesseurs.